[موسيقى]
في أوقات أكثر سعادة
أنقذت الأطفال من سوء المعاملة
[الموسيقى]
دفعت ثمنها بأرباح من
شركة بناء بنتها
الآن وهي مختبئة من طالبان
خوفًا على حياتها
يحاولون
تهديدنا وإعدامنا سراً كما فعلوا.  بالنسبة للعديد
من صديقاتي ،
فإن الجريمة التي ارتكبتها في عيون طالبان احتجاجًا على الخروج
إلى الشوارع قبل أسبوعين
للمطالبة بحقوق متساوية
تعرضت للضرب والكدمات
منذ أن طاردتها تهديدات طالبان
بالقتل لدرجة أنها تأمل الآن
إذا جاء الموت بسرعة
فأنا.  لا تخاف من الموت لكنني أتمنى عندما
يجدونني يقتلونني بسرعة إذا
عذبوني أولاً ، ثم
يقتلونني بدون أي شرف ، الجميع يريد
أن يموت بكرامة
قبل أن ترشح طالبان التي كانت معروفة جيدًا
للبرلمان ،
إذا  ليس من أجل
الفساد المستشري ، كانت تأمل
أن تنقذ شهرتها البارزة لها
الآن ليس لديها أي فكرة عما يجب أن أفعله إلى
متى يمكنني أن أكون شجاعًا إلى متى
يجب أن نكافح في الواقع مع من
نتحدث معه  هوم لمناقشة
أننا في الظلام مع عدم وجود طريقة للوصول
إلى مستقبل أكثر إشراقًا
[موسيقى] في
جميع أنحاء البلاد يختبئ العديد من النساء مثل
سادي خوفًا من طالبان ،
حيث يشاركن جميع منشورات وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي الجديدة
التي يقولون إنها تظهر إساءة
تعسفية وكلاهما  يصعب التحقق منها
وتنفي طالبان
في الوقت الحالي على الرغم من أنها الطريقة الوحيدة التي
يمكن للنساء من خلالها الاحتجاج على محنتهن ،
كل شيء على المحك الآن لأننا في
الواقع نواجه
موقفًا لا نرغب به كثيرًا من
قبل مجموعة من
الأشخاص الذين يديرون هذا بالفعل
البلد الذي لا يمكنهم حتى النظر إلينا
مابوبا سوراج هي الناشطة الأفغانية
البارزة في مجال حقوق المرأة التي
عادت من الولايات المتحدة عندما
أُطيح بطالبان قبل عقدين من الزمن ، وهي لن
تغادر مرة أخرى ، وتقول إنها ستبقى هنا
للدفاع عن النساء لجذب انتباه العالم.
سوف يتسببون في مشاكل
أنهم سوف يرفعون أصواتهم
وسوف يبدؤونها تعلمون
أنهم يستطيعون أن يصبح العالم
مكانًا صغيرًا جدًا الآن هؤلاء هم الرجال
المتوحشون المسلحين الذين يستديرون  إنهم على حشود
أه هذا صحيح ، لكن إلى متى
سيقتلون الجميع هو أن ما يريدون أن يفعلوه صعيدي
يواجه خيارًا مؤلمًا هي
معيلة عائلة شقيقها
والأطفال الذين أنقذتهم من سوء المعاملة يعتمدون عليها
وهم يحتاجونني  لذلك أنا بحاجة إلى أن أكون
قويًا وهذا صعب حقًا ،
لكن البقاء هو المخاطرة بالموت ،
لقد حاولنا كثيرًا أن نحظى بحياة أفضل في
أفغانستان للحصول
على مستقبل أفضل في الواقع ،
لم أكن أتوقع أنا وأصدقائي يومًا ما أننا
ستضطر لمغادرة بلدنا
لكنهم أخذوا كل شيء منا.
ما يحدث الآن تقول إنه يعتمد
على دعواتها للمساعدة في الولايات المتحدة والمملكة المتحدة
وكندا وآخرين
إذا تركت عهود صعيدي للقتال
على
نيك روبرتسون سي إن كابول
أفغانستان